auchel le prince vous êtes à port au
prince il ya certains qui qui doutent
fortement que les meurtriers
trouver le bon faire face aux
conséquences de leurs actes oui alors
bon vous avez d'un côté l' enquête
policière avec l'assistance des
américains et des colombiens vous avez
lé enquête judiciaire qui a commencé et
là c'est ça se passe au parquet c'est le
commissaire du gouvernement qui entend
des témoins disons il les a invité les a
pas convoqué et les premiers sur la
liste
je voulais les normes parce que c'est
quand même intéressant c'est l'ex
sénateur steeven benoit l'ancien député
youri latortue et surtout deux hommes
d'affaires très puissant ici réginald
boulos et dimitri vorbe qui eux sont à
l'étranger dont qu'ils étaient
représentés par leurs avocats et ce
qu'ils ont en commun ces gens là c'est
que ce sont des opposants
c'était des opposants farouches très
critique du président joël moïse alors
on veut les entendre parce qu'ils
avaient des choses à dire sur lui et ils
savent peut-être sont peut-être des
pistes pour le pur pour trouver les
auteurs intellectuels de l'attentât
c'est ce que recherche le parquet et il
ya des haïtiens qui n'hésitent pas à les
pointer du doigt en disant mais ils sont
derrière ces gens riches y sont derrière
ce meurtre
c'est certain alors maintenant on peut
se demander si évidemment on saura un
jour la vérité ici sur cette affaire on
peut on peut en douter
parce que l'impunité c'est la règle
disons ici alors j'ai posé la question
aux doyens justement du tribunal de port
au prince
et voilà ce qui m'a répondu vous
entendrez après la version d'un
chroniqueur judiciaire qui elle n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait la même le
vague
ils libèrent parfois est substitut qui
est mou ni même le commissaire du
gouvernement parfois ils laissaient pas
même le doyenné sait pas donc ici même
la personne qui a assassiné les cuisines
dès qu'il est puissant de qu'il a de
l'argent mais il était libre oui c'est
l'occasion pour nous de prouver que
notre système judiciaire est à même de
mener de contre enquête
c'est l'occasion pour nous ne pouvait
pas 1% public de la justice haïtienne
est capable d'arrêter et de juger tous
ceux qui commettent des infractions sur
le territoire national et jean michel il
ya des agents fédéraux américains en
haïti
alors voilà ça c'est une sorte de
caution un petit peu pour la le côté
policier de la faire bien sûr pas
judiciaire il ya des américains il ya
des colombiens et ça donne un petit peu
plus de confiance pour les haïtiens qui
jusqu'à présent estiment que peu du côté
de la police et l'habilité de la même
façon dans les américains sont prêts à
aider ils ont commencé de cette façon là
et vous allez entendre ce qu'a dit le
président mbaye donne pour la suite
oui mouvoir
alors demain d'autres personnes ont été
invitées par le commissaire du
gouvernement
ce sont des membres de la sécurité du
président juvenal maurice dont le chef
dimitri est rare qui effectué
dernièrement beaucoup de voyage en
colombie on se demande pourquoi on se
demande surtout pourquoi et comment ces
agents de sécurité sécurité ont laissé
entrer les mercenaires colombiens et
laisser assassiner le président qu'il
devait protéger
très bien merci beaucoup notre envoyé
spécial en haïti jean michel leprince
merci au revoir